in our morning rounds the FDA has just
approved the first drug to treat
postpartum depression this condition
affects more than 400,000 women every
year an estimated 20% of new mothers in
the United States dr. Tara a new ruler
spoke to one of the handful of women who
have tried the drug and shows us it's
very dramatic results good morning to
you Tara good morning Gail postpartum
depression can strike out of the blue
during what is supposed to be a special
time it's estimated that half of cases
go undiagnosed current treatments can
take weeks or months to bring relief now
a fast-acting infusion given in the
hospital may offer new hope to families
affected by postpartum depression I
remember being in that picture Stephanie
and Adam Hathaway had just moved to
China when they became parents for the
first time she was the same size as
monkey shortly after daughter Hadley was
born Stephanie started sliding into
depression I had intrusive thoughts it
was your husband deserves a better wife
your children deserve a better mom what
had you expected to feel when the baby
was born instant love inhalation and
connection and they put her on my chest
and I felt nothing when Hadley was just
a few weeks old Adam got a frightening
call at work kenchi said I need you to
come home and then there was this very
real fear of what I might do if I put
the baby down so that's I think when
we're really kind of we had to go and
ask for help
symptoms of postpartum depression can
include sadness anxiety irritability
loss of appetite self-harm including
suicide and loss of interest in the new
baby
what did postpartum depression take away
from you it took everything
it took my hope it stole my joy it stole
time those precious newborn months I
don't remember them at all after three
months on antidepressants stephanie was
feeling more like her old self she and
Adam relocated to Connecticut and move
forward with their plans for a larger
family when she became pregnant with
daughter Brenly Stephanie went back on
medication as a precaution how soon
after
the birth of your second child did you
start to feel those same symptoms the
crying was immediate it was darker than
the first time the thoughts were more
intense and the fear of what I might do
was even worse this time antidepressants
didn't help hey daddy
so Stephanie signed up for a clinical
trial of a new kind of medicine so Rezo
targets specific brain receptors to
rebalance the hormones that spike during
pregnancy and plummet after birth dr.
Samantha Meltzer Brody chief of
perinatal psychiatry at the University
of North Carolina led the trials and
says fast-acting relief is vital the
currently available treatments are not
going to work for generally a month or
more that's really hard to look at
someone and say I know you're suffering
tremendously and we're going to start
treatment and maybe a month from now
you'll feel better the new medicine is a
one-time intravenous treatment that
requires a three-night hospital stay in
clinical trials of more than 200 women
70% had improved mood appetite sleep and
functioning
Stephanie felt better on her very first
day between hours 12 and 18 I noticed a
huge difference those intrusive thoughts
I told you about were gone and they
never came back and so I called my
husband and tell him about it and he
says Stephanie I haven't heard the you
and your voice and so long the same
wonderful woman I married I went to
China with gone through life with us he
was back again it was a really good
feeling did your daughter say anything
to you did she notice a change she told
me she loved me and it was good to have
me back and I took that as more than
just coming home women in the clinical
trials were followed for 30 days with
most finding relief side effects may
include sleepiness dizziness and
headache it's expected to cost between
20 and 35 thousand dollars treatment
sounds very intense does insurance cover
it well insurance may cover it's gonna
depend on your insurance plan so you
have to check that up what's the
difference between I'm overwhelmed by
this baby because they are a lot of work
especially if it's your first and you
really have a serious problem right so
there is something called baby blues
which many women experience that's
usually within the first couple days or
weeks
but if it really persists longer you
know it's starting at two weeks goes
four months or even a year and it
interferes with their functioning and
that's really the important point that's
when you know that a maybe I have tipped
over into something that's more serious
so to every mother be screened for
postpartum depression absolutely and you
know not only should it be the job of
the ob/gyns but more and more the
pediatricians are getting involved
because in many cases they interface
with the mom in those first few months
more than anyone else spouses need to be
aware you know but one of the things we
were talking about is why is this not
mandated part of hospital education
before a woman gets discharged we teach
breathing we teach infant CPR started
wrapped the baby and we're not telling
women these are the signs and symptoms
of postpartum depression I remember
after I had both of my children the
first thing the doctor did was turn to
my husband and say here's what you need
to look out for when you're gonna be
home with her and he was vigilant about
both of those I mean how important is
that for the spouse you know what to do
and look out for extremely important and
you know the spouse in this particular
story said the same thing you know he
really didn't know he didn't know what
to do and some of the things he did in
the beginning of saying everything's
great we have a wonderful baby actually
made it worse so it's important to
educate both mom and spouse can you ever
- not know it you could because some of
the symptoms may not be what you think
it may be excessively watching the baby
you know or anger or anxiety so it may
not look like what you think you know
postpartum depression should look like
but really we want to just tell women
please speak out you know this isn't
something that you have to suffer in
silence with don't be embarrassed by it
don't be embarrassed don't be ashamed
need to get rid of the stigma around
this it's a hormonal imbalance we think
you know we don't know really the true
underlying physiology but the thought is
the reason this drug might work is that
you know as it mentioned your hormones
drop after pregnancy and this particular
drug is a breakdown product of
progesterone you're giving it back
essentially very important information
thank you Tara for resources on
postpartum depression you can call the
postpartum support international
helpline there is one at one eight
hundred nine four four four PPD that's
one eight hundred nine forty four for
PPD and there is a link on our website
CBS this morning calm